y
[Música]
en el día 51 desde que inició la guerra
en ucrania rusia aseguró que atacó una
fábrica de misiles a las afueras de
quiebre y advirtió que aumentara la
ofensiva contra la capital ante lo que
considera ataques terroristas y de
sabotaje en territorio ruso por su parte
del gobierno regional de heart kit
denunció un bombardeo contra un área
residencial que dejó 7 muertos y 34
heridos
el último sobreviviente de los comandos
que realizaron los atentados de 2015 en
parís pidió perdón por primera vez a las
víctimas para algunos de los asistentes
al juicio se trata de un discurso
fabricado que no revela el verdadero
sentir de sala abdeslam
se cumple el tercer aniversario del
incendio en la catedral del sol donde
parís se espera que el monumento pueda
abrir sus puertas en 2024 por lo que en
las próximas semanas iniciarán las obras
de restauración del formato original
a ustedes gracias por continuar con
nosotros en france 24 soy valentina
torres sánchez y es un gusto
acompañarlos iniciamos hablando de la
guerra en ucrania se cumplen 51 días de
ofensiva y el ministerio ruso aseguró
que bombardeo una fábrica de misiles
ubicada a las afueras de kiev al tiempo
indicó que redoblará la ofensiva en la
capital ucraniana ante actos que
considere terroristas o de sabotaje el
anuncio se da el mismo día en que fueron
denunciados bombardeos en kharkiv con
siete fallecidos y en mykolaiv con cinco
víctimas marinas ardilla tiene los
detalles
en el día 51 de guerra nuclear rusia
advirtió que intensificará los ataques
con misiles sobre kiev después de que
durante la noche se escucharon fuertes
explosiones las más significativas en la
capital ucraniana prueba el número y la
escala de los ataques con misiles contra
objetivos en quien aumentaran en
respuesta a cualquier ataque terrorista
o sabotaje cometido por el régimen
nacionalista de que en el territorio
ruso
la ciudad dejar al menos siete personas
entre ellos un menor de edad murieron y
una treintena resultaron heridas después
de los bombardeos rusos sobre una zona
residencial
dos niños que estaban en el patio de
recreo resultaron heridos fueron heridos
y llevados al hospital algunos de los
bólidos este viernes moscú aseguró que
sus tropas habían tomado el control de
la planta metalúrgica y leeds en la
sitiada mariupol la tierra portuaria ha
sido el escenario de los combates más
brutales entre las tropas rusas y las
fuerzas ucranianas que anunciaron que
rusia usó misiles de largo alcance por
primera vez
utilizaron bombarderos de largo alcance
tu 22 m3 y bombarderos 334 y 4
de
las fuerzas terrestres enemigas están
tratando de capturar el puerto marítimo
vídeo región y moxico oportuno el
kremlin también advirtió a la casa
blanca que si eeuu continúa enviando
armas a ucrania habrá consecuencias
impredecibles
las fuerzas de vladimir putin están
intensificando sus ataques en el este y
sur del país como aparente represalia
luego de perder un buque insignia en el
mar negro que según ucrania fue
alcanzado por sus misiles
entretanto el director de la cia william
burns aseguró que no debe descartarse la
posibilidad de que rusia utilice armas
nucleares en ucrania el funcionario
explicó que el kremlin podría usar este
tipo de armamento ante las
complicaciones con las que se ha
encontrado en medio de la ofensiva en el
terreno no obstante detalló que hasta el
momento no hay pruebas concluyentes de
que moscú ya esté preparando este tipo
de ataques
tras progresión da la desesperación
potencial del presidente putin y el
liderazgo ruso dado los reveses que han
enfrentado militarmente hasta ahora
ninguno de nosotros puede tomar a la
ligera la amenaza que representa un
recurso potencial de las armas nucleares
tácticas o armas nucleares de bajo
rendimiento web vamos ahora a chile en
la convención constitucional aprobó el
artículo que da luz verde a la
reelección presidencial inmediata por
una sola vez asimismo el órgano
disminuyó de 35 a 30 años la edad
obligatoria para ser jefe de estado y
también aprobó cerrar el senado para
analizar esta información conectamos con
la abogada sandra ponce de léon magíster
en derecho público con mención en
derecho constitucional por la pontificia
universidad católica de chile y ex
relatora del tribunal constitucional
bienvenida france24 como toma la
sociedad chilena estas medidas
buenas noches antes que todo bueno con
un con algo de preocupación
se ha visto no acepto que el trabajo que
ha desarrollado la convención hasta
ahora
ha sido bastante
importante el cambio que quieren hacer o
qué quieren unos ciertos reflejará en la
constitución respecto del sistema
político y uno de esos cambios
importantes relevantes para nuestra
historia constitucional es la
eliminación del senado y transformarlo
en un órgano de representación regional
pero que aún no se sabe cuáles van a ser
sus sus atribuciones
las mínimas atribuciones que debieran
estar previstas en la constitución para
que luego el legislador las desarrolle
yo creo que esa es una expectativa no es
cierto que tiene la ciudadanía hoy día
de saber que es precisamente este nuevo
órgano y además digamos de las normas
que van a regular la presidencia de la
república
una manera en octubre de 2020 cuando se
realizó el plebiscito nacional un 80 por
ciento de los participantes aprobó la
convención y es un órgano que ha
generado muy altas expectativas en el
país e incluso en la región pero por
primera vez en abril varios sondeos
muestran que son más los chilenos que
rechazarían el borrador de la carta
magna con lo que hasta el momento se ha
aprobado cómo se puede interpretar esta
tendencia
yo creo que repitiendo un poco esto yo
creo que efectivamente hubo una muy alta
expectativa respecto del trabajo que
podría hacer la convención y yo creo que
hoy día en la convención aún no se ha
involucrado en aquellos temas que
efectivamente la sociedad espera de
ellos que son precisamente aquellos
temas relacionados con el reconocimiento
el incentivo y la protección de los
derechos sociales más bien se han
conocido lo cierto normas que regulan el
sistema político o el régimen del
ejercicio del poder pero todavía no se
niega a eso por lo tanto la ciudadanía
todavía no entiende si se está o no
cumpliendo el mandato que se le dio en
octubre a la convención constitucional
esta semana el presidente de gabriel
brito estuvo en argentina y dijo que
estaba preocupado por la caída del apoyo
y que las dudas respecto al trabajo de
la convención no deben ser ignoradas que
camino tiene este órgano en estos
momentos
yo creo que el camino básico nos está
seguir avanzando seguir trabajando y yo
sé que el trabajo ha sido arduo
y hay intención evidentemente de buena
fe de modificar y el digamos algunos
algunos paradigmas que se han venido
dando en nuestro país precisamente y que
dieron cuenta en lo cierto el estadio
social desde octubre yo creo que hay que
seguir trabajando y con mucho ahínco y
mostrando precisamente aquellos avances
que puede hacer la constitución y que se
lo van a dejar después al legislador
precisamente en esa en materia de
resguardo la seguridad social de la
salud mejoramiento de la educación yo
creo que sin esos avances va a ser muy
difícil que la ciudadanía pueda no
cierto
un poco compartir y asumir no es cierto
que el trabajo de la convención ha sido
fructífero y por eso la
señora ponce de león a usted muchas
gracias por su análisis y por
compartirlo con nosotros en france 24
y diremos
cambiamos de tema en jerusalén más de
150 palestinos y tres policías israelíes
resultaron heridos tras enfrentamientos
en la explanada de las mezquitas los
choques se dieron incluso al interior de
la mezquita de al-aqsa uno de los
lugares más sagrados para el islam los
hechos amenazan con empeorar la ya tensa
situación entre israel y los palestinos
en las últimas semanas más de una decena
de personas ha perdido la vida manuel
acá no nos amplia
la explanada de las mezquitas de
jerusalén es nuevamente escenario de
enfrentamientos la policía israelí
aseguró haber intervenido para
contrarrestar a un grupo de palestinos
que lanzaban piedras y petardos tras la
oración del segundo viernes del ramadán
contestaron con bombas aturdidoras y
gases lacrimógenos obligando a los
asistentes a refugiarse decenas de
palestinos resultaron heridos según la
media luna roja los hechos se
presentaron incluso dentro de la propia
mezquita al-aqsa el tercer lugar más
sagrado del islám donde la presencia de
las fuerzas de seguridad de israel es
considerada por los musulmanes como un
acto de provocación
cientos de palestinos fueron detenidos
la ocupación sabe que la mezquita de
al-aqsa es una línea roja que no debe
cruzarse por esta mezquita sacrificamos
nuestros corazones y nuestra sangre y lo
condenamos en nombre de nuestro pueblo y
de todos los presentes en la mezquita
las tensiones se dan cuando coinciden
las celebraciones de ramadán musulmán la
pascua judía y la semana santa cristiana
y tras una serie de atentados que en las
últimas semanas han dejado 14 israelíes
muertos las operaciones militares de
israel en cisjordania terminaron con la
muerte de 29 palestinos pago por el
empleo estamos trabajando para calmar
las cosas en el monte del templo y en
todo israel al mismo tiempo estamos
preparados para cualquier escenario es
un panorama delicado y al que se le suma
la condena del grupo hamas que aseguró
que israel tiene la responsabilidad de
las consecuencias el año pasado una ola
de enfrentamientos en jerusalén con yo
una intervención militar israelí en la
franja de gaza cobrándose la vida de 250
palestinos y 13 israelíes
vamos ahora hasta el tribunal especial
de asís de parís donde continúa el
juicio por los atentados del 13 de
noviembre de 2015 sala de slam el último
sobreviviente de los comandos
terroristas que mataron a 130 personas e
hirieron a más de 400 tuvo su más
reciente interrogatorio y por primera
vez pidió perdón por los atentados
ampliamos en el siguiente informe
lágrimas y disculpas esta fue la
respuesta de salas de slam a las
preguntas de los abogados sobre lo
ocurrido en la noche del 13 de noviembre
de 2015 y sobre su vida a bélgica de pie
en el palco con la voz temblorosa se
dirigió a las víctimas
ofrezco mis condolencias y mis disculpas
hablo para todas las víctimas
hoy les pido que me odien con moderación
una disculpa tardía y sorprendente
algunas de las víctimas quedaron
visiblemente desconcertadas no estoy
seguro de su sinceridad pero tampoco de
lo contrario es mi hija la que fue
asesinada no puedo perdonar por ellas
para la fiscalía sala de slam adapta
constantemente su discurso las
circunstancias y para demostrarlo el
tribunal difundió una entrevista con
sala de slam mientras suya de francia la
noche del 13 al 14 de noviembre de 2015
en aquel momento todavía no había sido
identificado por los investigadores y
fingió estar sorprendido por los
numerosos controles en la carretera
desde que estoy aquí es el tercero y
francamente nos pareció un poco abusivo
pero luego supimos por qué son azul y
poco para algunos esa es la verdadera
cara de salad slam
tenemos un discurso bastante construido
y pulido excepto cuando llegamos a los
elementos que conciernen a su ego porque
en cuanto hablamos del eco debemos
enderezarse inflar la voz y ser más
sólido también podemos ver cuando nos
remontamos a lo ocurrido en el momento
de los hechos tenía una extraordinaria
compostura incluso en el momento de la
huida y como mother y el acusado no
deberá volver a hablar ante la justicia
hasta finales de junio cuando se le dará
la palabra por última vez justo antes
del veredicto
en pocas semanas los mejores carpinteros
y restauradores de francia se turnarán
para reconstruir la catedral la catedral
de notre-dame hoy hace tres años el 15
de abril de 2019 este monumento parisino
se incendió y quedó destruido desde
entonces se ha emprendido un enorme reto
para restaurar el histórico sitio antes
de 2024 en otra edad vuelve a estar en
pie el marco del edificio ya fue
estabilizado
ahora comienza la reconstrucción tres
años después de que ardiera en llamas
desde cirujanos de árboles hasta
pintores múltiples artesanos de toda
francia están usando sus habilidades
para restaurar la catedral y devolverle
su antigua gloria
las obras datan de los siglos 17 y 18
aunque al principio no estaba claro si
los monumentos al óleo sobre lienzo
podrían sobrevivir al incendio
[Música]
y restaurar los cuadros es una mezcla
una mezcla de barniz con un poco de
repintado algunas de las pinturas han
quedado muy oscuras por las llamas al
principio pensé que no podían ser
restauradas pero no fue así de hecho
están libres de los contaminantes del
incendio of eso son de posición
la restauración de las pinturas llevará
dos años tiempo exacto para la
reapertura de la catedral
en el resto de francia se están talando
árboles antiguos en los bosques de todo
el país la madera se utilizará para
reconstruir la aguja de notredame que se
diseñará tal y como se hizo
originalmente en el siglo 19 lo que
significa que se necesitarán 1000 roble
y la catedral también va a recuperar su
voz los ocho mil tubos del gran órgano
se están limpiando
mientras los artesanos perfecciona la
reconstrucción de su interior
se trata de la experiencia para nosotros
es imponente
se han prometido unos 845 millones de
euros de donantes privados y
empresariales para la restauración de
notredame que debe terminar a tiempo
para su primer servicio completo
previsto para el 16 de abril de 2024
tras dos años de pandemia el papá
francisco regresó al coliseo de roma
para celebrar el vía crucis miles de
fieles asistieron a la conmemoración
marcada por la guerra en ucrania aunque
el pontífice no hizo una mención directa
a pidió seguir el camino de la paz y
dejar las armas para que florezca la
concordia
antes de finalizar esta emisión los
invito a conectarse con directo américa
edición nocturna donde mi compañero
santiago lópez y yo nos acompañaremos
con todas las noticias el debate y las
actualizaciones de los deportes y la
economía desde este lunes 18 de abril a
las 19 horas de bogotá quito y lima
llegamos hacia el final de esta
informativo les agradecemos su sintonía
feliz noche para todos
[Música]